MALE SPEAKER: Good morning.
Welcome to Authors@Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, it's my great pleasure
to introduce one of the most
interesting and successful
people I know,
Hank Phillippi Ryan.
Hank is the Anthony-, Agatha-,
Macavity-award-winning author
of five mystery novels--
"Prime Time," "Face Time," "Air
Time," "Drive Time," and
now "The Other Woman," which
is front of you, her first
recent hardcover, which went
back for a second printing, I
think, the first week.
So it's been highly
successful.
More than an author, which would
be enough, Hank has also
been an award-winning
investigative reporter at
Boston's Channel 7
for 27 years--
no, 30 years.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Yesterday
was my 30-year anniversary, in
Boston, only.
MALE SPEAKER: You started
at age 5?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN:
Aw, thank you, Sam.
Get this guy another book.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: And she has almost
as many Emmys as she
has years at Channel 7--
28 Emmys, and those are real
Emmys, not Daytime Emmys or
Golden Globes.
So they mean something.
Before Channel 7, she
was a reporter.
I know she'll talk
about those days.
She toured the country with
the photographer Richard
Avedon and Hunter S. Thompson.
I told her just now, you haven't
written a book about
touring with Thompson.
And she said, nobody
would believe it.
I think we should demand
it here, today.
America wants to
read this book.
But without further ado,
Hank Philippi Ryan.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Thank
you, thank you so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Thank
you so much for
inviting me here today.
The Hunter Thompson story
that I cannot tell
is we went to Florida.
We were doing a series
of stories on the '76
presidential election, and we
were interviewing all the
possible candidates for the
Democratic nomination.
And we went to Florida
to interview--
I can't even remember
who it was.
I was a kid, I was 21 or
something like that, so this
is pretty interesting.
So it was Hunter Thompson
and Pat Caddell.
Do you remember Pat Caddell from
the political campaign?
And Bob Shrum.
And we all went to a hotel
room in Florida.
And Hunter taught me how to
inhale lighter fluid and then
light it on fire, so you
could breathe fire.
Do not try this at home.
And I couldn't do it now
if you asked me to.
But here we are in, like, the
Hilton or something like that,
playing with lighter fluid
and lighting it on fire.
We all thought we
were hilarious.
I would not do that now, but
that's just part of the story.
Hunter and I went out
to dinner once in
Washington, DC, and--
you're set with who Hunter
Thompson is, right?
You're OK.
Went out to dinner in
Washington, DC.
And it was so long ago that the
Metro system in Washington
hadn't been built yet.
So the streets were
all torn up.
The streets were wooden
in Washington, DC.
It was 1971 or so.
The streets were wooden
and slick, and it was
pouring down rain.
And Hunter has this rental car
that's fishtailing through the
streets of Washington
on this wet wood.
And he says, wow, I hope the
police don't stop us.
I hope we don't get into an
accident, because the police
will go crazy when they find
out what's in the trunk.
I'm like, really?
I'm a reporter for "Rolling
Stone Magazine." I don't want
to be with Hunter Thompson when
the police come and we
all get arrested and I have to
call my mom in Indianapolis
and say, guess what?
And I'm sure he was kidding.
I'm sure he was kidding.
I never looked in the
trunk to make sure.
So we go out to dinner to,
like, Don Juan's or
something like that.
Mexican restaurant.
And Hunter orders
five margaritas.
And I'm like, you're not even
going to drink five
margaritas.
Why would you do that?
And he says, I just
want to see if the
waitress will bring them.
I just want to see
if she will.
So that's kind of what
he was like.
He was also so generous.
I mean, he came across as this
gonzo journalist who was tough
and wacky and crazy and nuts--
I mean, nuts.
But he was really the kindest,
most gentle person you could
possibly imagine.
And here's how long
ago it was.
He asked me if I had ever
heard of Jimmy Buffett.
And I said, no.
So that's how long ago it was.
And he said, well,
come with me.
And he took me to
a record store.
You OK on record store?
[LAUGHTER]
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: He took
me to a record store and
bought me all the Jimmy
Buffett albums,
which I still have.
So that's a generous heart.
That is a wonderful guy.
So when I look back on those
years, working in Washington,
DC during Watergate, during
the Nixon presidency, when
Woodward and Bernstein's
articles were
coming out every day.
Then I transitioned to covering
the Ford White House
for "Rolling Stone"
for a while.
I did a column called "Capitol
Chatter," which was sort of
Washington gossip.
Now we had a three-week
lead time.
So if you can imagine doing a
gossip column when it has to
hold and be new for
three weeks?
That just like, gossip is gone
in a moment, so nothing's
going to hold for three weeks.
So I did stuff like, I covered
Susan Ford's prom
at the White House.
That was pretty surreal
and kind of great.
So it was a fun time.
But this, I'm here for "The
Other Woman," although when
I'm finish the yapping, I'll
be delighted to answer any
questions about any realm of
my career that you like--
writing or thinking or
imagination or reporting or
investigative reporting or
mysteries or television, or
anything like that.
But when I see "The
Other Woman"--
this is my first hardcover--
I love it.
It is in a second printing
already.
It's been on the Boston Globe
bestseller list twice, went to
number two.
That pesky "Gone Girl"
is number one.
Can't imagine.
But what I also didn't imagine,
when I wrote this
book, is that the cover
would look like this.
It says, Hank Phillippi
Ryan, "The
Other Woman." [LAUGHTER]
No.
I should have thought that
through a little bit more.
And the second book in the
series, which comes out next
year, is called "The Wrong
Girl." Hank Phillippi Ryan,
"The Wrong Girl."
So I need to think, and maybe
you can help me at some point,
think of a better title
for the third book.
Hank Phillippi Ryan, "Really
Good." Or Hank Phillippi Ryan,
"Buy This Book." Or something
like that, that is a little
more encouraging.
You know, this juxtaposition of
title reminds me of a story
that we did a couple
of years ago.
As you know, I'm the
investigative
reporter at Channel 7.
I've just worked there
now for 30 years.
Yesterday is my anniversary.
Crazy.
But since 1988, I've been
the investigative
reporter at Channel 7.
And we did a story a couple
of years ago on
headlights on cars.
Not head lice, but headlights
on cars, and how they
diminish, their power diminishes
over time.
And people think that they can't
see as well, but really
it's that their headlights
aren't working as well as they
did before.
So I promise you this
has a point.
We got 20 cars from a car dealer
and lined them up,
everything from like a 1999 Ford
Gizmo or whatever they
had, to like the big, flashy
Jaguar something or other,
with xenon headlights, or
xeon, or whatever it is.
And we lined them all up
and we turned on the
headlights at night.
And we had a guy who was an
expert in lighting calibrate
the light that came, the
foot candles that
came from each headlight.
And sure enough, it turned out
that the headlights got worse
as time went by.
The bulbs themselves would get
dim, and the plastic in the
headlight cover would get thick
and opaque and make it
more difficult to see.
So here's a good story.
We thought, good.
This is a good story.
People need to know this.
So we reported the story.
I wrote the story.
I went into the edit booth,
and I edited the story and
made a little movie out of it.
And you know, the last thing
that you do before a story
goes on TV, an investigative
story, is you do the stand-up
in the newsroom, the stand-up
close to the story.
Come on in.
The stand-up close to the
story, which is when the
reporter stands in front of the
graphic that describes the
story and says, for more on
this, go to our website.
Yap, yap, yap.
So I put on my spiffy little
reporter suit and a whole
bunch of makeup and combed my
hair and I'm going down to the
newsroom to stand in front
of the graphic.
And I turn around,
and the graphic--
like this--
the graphic says
"Dangerously Dim." [LAUGHTER]
And I said to the dude--
So I go to the news director,
and I say, I cannot stand in
front of a graphic that says
"Dangerously Dim." And he
laughed, just like you did.
And then he goes, Yeah,
we don't really
have time to fix that.
So I had to stand in front
of this graphic that says
"Dangerously Dim." The only
thing that I've ever seen
that's sort of worse than that
is we had an anchorwoman, this
gorgeous anchorwoman, who had to
stand in front of a graphic
that said, "Botched
Plastic Surgery." [LAUGHTER]
So these are things that
you just don't
think about, as viewers.
Things that the art department
ought to think about,
but they rarely do.
But as I said, I've been a
reporter for 30 years.
I've wired myself with
hidden cameras.
I've confronted corrupt
politicians.
I've chased down criminals.
I've gone in disguise and
undercover and been
tear-gassed and gotten to close
to fires and been to
murder scenes.
And gosh, interviewed everybody
from Jimmy Carter to
Muhammad Ali to Prince
Charles.
And it's been fabulous.
You know, I love my
job as a reporter.
It's one of those--
it's one of those professions
where every day you go to
work, and you have no idea
what's going to happen.
And that's good.
That's good.
I have a cartoon--
I think it's a "Zippy."
No, it isn't.
I have a cartoon on my
refrigerator that has two guys
on a desert island, clearly
by themselves.
And one of them says other, you
mean we're out here on our
own in the middle of nowhere?
We have no idea what's going to
happen, and no control over
our future?
And the second guy says, Yeah.
And the first guy says, Cool.
And that's sort of how I look at
the world, that there's so
many open doors and so many
possibilities and so many
things that could happen,
and everything
could turn into a story.
Now when I started in
my real, grown-up--
my first job was at the Dairy
Queen, and I can still make
the dip cone with the
curlicue on top,
which I may need someday.
But my first real job in
grown-up world was as a
campaign worker, political
staffer in a political
campaign in my home
in Indiana.
You know, and I took constituent
calls and
organized advance teams and went
to county fairs and flew
in the helicopter with the
candidate and ate corn dogs
and wrote press releases
and stuff like that.
And I really got an inside view
of what it's like to work
in politics.
What politicians want,
what candidates want.
How they think, what they need,
the desire for power.
How they manipulate,
how they try to
manipulate how we think.
No matter what's really true,
that they want you to think
what they want to think.
And at that time, I thought I
wanted to be in politics.
But what happened was, sadly,
none of the candidates I ever
worked for actually won.
And I began to think
that perhaps I had
chosen the wrong field.
Not that I was in charge, no.
I was 20.
But nevertheless, this
was not going my way.
And I have a pretty abiding
philosophy that when something
bad happens in your life, it
only means that something
fabulous is going to
happen soon after.
I mean, you've had this happen,
that you think, oh my
goodness, I'm so disappointed,
I'm doomed.
My life is over.
I will never be OK.
And then soon after, some
fabulous thing occurs that
makes you realize that if the
bad thing hadn't happened, the
good thing wouldn't have
happened next.
You know what I mean?
You've had that.
And so that is exactly why
I am where I am today, is
because no politician who I ever
worked for actually won.
And here's why.
When a guy who was running for
governor of Indiana lost the
election, I was out of a job.
And instead of being a hotshot
campaign aide to the governor
of Indiana, I was unemployed.
I was unemployed.
And an English major, so
skill-less and unemployed.
Completely unemployable.
So I went to the biggest radio
station in Indianapolis, my
hometown, and applied for
the job as a reporter.
They had a job opening
for a reporter.
This was 1970?
'71.
1971.
I applied for the job
as a reporter.
And the news director,
this guy who was
kind of like Lou Grant--
remember Lou Grant?
Sort of crusty but benign.
He says, well, do you
have any experience?
Do you have any experience
as a reporter?
Have you ever written
a news story?
Have you ever interviewed
anyone?
Have you ever written
a news release?
Have you ever covered
any kind of a story?
Did you go to journalism
school?
Work on the school paper?
Anything.
I'm like, oh, drat.
No.
I have no experience.
The dreaded experience
question.
Nothing.
But I was young, and I thought,
I can do this.
He should just hire me.
So I said, no, I don't really
have any experience, but I
grew up here in Indianapolis
and I know where all the
streets are.
You kind of got to go
with what you have.
And I said, and your license is
up for renewal at the FCC,
and you don't have any
women working here.
And then I just smiled.
And the next day, I had my first
job in broadcasting.
[LAUGHTER]
And here's why I
tell you this.
Here's why I tell you this.
One, because it won't
work anymore.
When I talk to journalism
classes, I say, don't go in
and say, you should hire
me because I'm a woman.
They're going to be like, yeah,
you and everybody else
in the office.
My boss is a woman, her
boss is a woman, and
her boss is a woman.
So that's very different from
how it was back then.
In the days when I started, when
Andrea Mitchell started,
with Leslie Stahl started, when
Nancy Dickerson started,
and Barbara Walters, and Jane
Pauley, all of us were
breaking the glass ceiling
for women in
broadcasting at the time.
When you walked into a newsroom
when I started back
in the '70s, everybody
was smoking,
everybody was yelling.
There was smoke and
cigarettes and
typewriters and people yelling.
And now they're quiet and full
of women and no smoking.
I mean, it's completely--
the world has changed
so incredibly much.
So who would have thought, back
in the day when you had
to get up to change
the channel--
do you remember that?--
you had to get up to change
the channel that now there
would be 900 channels and
Diane Sawyer would be
anchoring "The Evening News?" I
mean, 35 years ago, that was
unthinkable.
So the world has definitely
changed since then.
But I think I knew, from the
moment I read my first
"Sherlock Holmes" story and my
first "Nancy Drew" book, that
I wanted to be a
mystery author.
You read "Nancy Drew."
Did you read "Nancy
Drew," the real ones?
There was "The Clue in the Old
Clock," and "The Clue in the
Diary," which I thought was
"Clue in the Dairy," for like
most of the book.
So I'm going, shouldn't there
be some cows in this?
There weren't.
I figured that out.
And then I went on to the
wonderful British woman
mystery authors, Margery
Allingham, Josephine Tey,
Ngaio Marsh, and of course,
Agatha Christie, my idol when
I was 13 years old.
And in the interesting sort of
synchronistic world, the way
it is, my first novel won the
Agatha for Best First Mystery.
So who'd have thought, you know,
this 13-year-old loving
Agatha Christie would 50 years
later win an award for Best
Traditional Mystery,
named after her?
So that's how the world is so
wonderful, and the world is so
mysterious.
But then one day, I sneaked from
my parents bookshelves
the book "Failsafe." Do you
remember "Failsafe" at all?
Really, really scary book
about the Cold War.
And I terrified myself.
And then I read "On the Beach,"
and "Seven Days in
May," and "Advise and Consent,"
and all these
wonderful, dark political
thrillers.
And I realized that there
was another kind of
literature out there.
It was suspense.
And that's what, all of that
goes into "The Other Woman."
But my life turned out a
different way, as you know.
I wasn't a mystery
author back then.
I turned out to be a television
reporter.
Because that day in
Indianapolis, when I talked to
the guy about the FCC, I took
a chance, I had some
confidence, and I found
my calling.
Just by chance.
I became a TV reporter.
And you might think that being
a reporter for television, an
investigative reporter,
and writing
fiction are very different.
And of course, they are, because
in television you
can't make stuff up.
This is the key difference.
But basically, in television
and in mystery writing,
they're very similar.
Because the key of both of them
is to tell a good story.
It's only and all about telling
a good story with a
wonderful plot and with
compelling characters, where
the good guys win and
the bad guys get
what's coming to them.
When at the end, there's a
satisfying ending with some
justice, and you get to change
the world a little bit.
And whether it's in television
or in fiction, that's my role,
to change the world
a little bit.
You know, every one of those
28 Emmys that I have
represents a secret that we
discovered that someone didn't
want you to know.
You know what I mean?
It's not just like
a good story.
But it's a thing that someone
was trying to keep you from
knowing that we revealed.
Quickly, in our stories, we did
stories about the mortgage
industry and home improvement
contractors in Massachusetts
that resulted in three new
laws being passed.
We got people's homes
out of foreclosure.
People's homes out
of foreclosure.
And millions of dollars in
refunds and restitution.
We discovered why there was no
diversity at all in federal
jury pools in Massachusetts, no
people of color at all for
years in federal jury pools
of Massachusetts.
No diversity, and we found
out why that was.
And now that's getting
changed.
We discovered that it's possible
that when you call
911 for emergency help, that the
police and firefighters,
the emergency responders,
were being sent
to the wrong address.
Over and over and over and over,
people were being sent
to the wrong address.
The state had no idea.
And we, as a result
of our story, that
system is being changed.
We had to battle up to the
Secretary of State's office to
get them to give us the
information about why you
weren't receiving your emergency
response in the
proper way.
So it's been very exciting.
Fiction and investigative
reporting
are all about secrets.
Who knows a secret?
Who has a secret?
Who's telling the secret.
Who's going to find
out the secret?
And what's going to happen
as a result of that?
So every day, what I do every
day is to look for secrets.
Also every day, I look
for a good idea.
And it's really fascinating to
me to think about, you know,
every story I write and every
book that I write starts with
the nugget of a wonderful
idea.
Harlan Coben--
do you know the author
Harlan Coben?--
talks about how he writhes on
the couch for a month to think
of his good story.
And all authors worry about
where their next
idea will come from.
And it's fascinating to
me to think about
how our minds work.
A couple of years ago, five
years ago, I was still looking
for a plot for my first book.
I got an email, a spam email,
and I was deleting all the
spam for my computer.
You know how you do that, just
blink, blink, blink, blink,
blink, because you recognize
it instantly.
And I opened one by mistake.
And in it--
the subject line said, a new
refinancing deal for you.
But in the body of the email
was what looked like lines
from a play by Shakespeare.
And I thought, why would
somebody put that there?
Why would someone put a
Shakespeare play in the body
of an email about mortgage
refinancing?
And it crossed my mind that it
might be a secret message.
And then I thought, oh my gosh,
ding, ding, ding, secret
messages in computer spam.
And I thought, that is an
idea for a mystery.
And that turned out to be "Prime
Time," my first book.
And I'll tell you that I went to
the FBI Citizen's Academy,
which is this eight-week course
that the FBI gives to
the public, to come in and
learn how they work.
So on the cyber crimes day, I
took aside the agent who was
in charge of federal cyber
crimes and I said, can I tell
you my idea for a mystery?
And can you imagine?
This guy's like, oh my gosh.
Here's some woman who
wants to tell me
her idea for a mystery.
Sure, lady, tell me the idea.
So I told him about the secret
messages in computer spam.
And his eyes got bigger and
bigger and bigger, and he
said, you know, that
would work.
And I said, I know.
And I said, have you ever
had any cases like that?
And he said, no.
And I said, well, maybe I
should've chosen a life of
crime rather than a life
as a mystery author.
And he says, no, watch it,
we're on to you now,
so don't try it.
You know why it would work.
I mean, you all know why it
would work, because it was
plain text.
I was seeing the plain text
instead of the HTML, and
somebody had just put that in.
But I didn't know that.
So it was just this incredible,
mysterious thing
that happened.
But like every other author--
every other author--
after I had a good idea, I
wondered if I would ever have
another good idea.
I say to my husband, I'm never
going to write another book,
because I'll never have
another good idea.
I'm never going to do another
investigative story, because
I'll never have another
good idea.
And he says, you always
say that.
And I say, I know, but this is
the time I'm never going to
have another good idea.
And he says, you always
say that too.
And I say, I know, but this
could be the time that I
really never have another
good idea.
And somehow, the universe,
it seems to me--
and I don't know if you've
had this happen to you.
But when you need the idea, when
it's really time for the
idea, the universe provides
the idea for you.
Have you had this?
It's unbelievable.
And if you just sort of let go
and be open to the thought,
sometimes it just shows up.
And I don't mean to
sound woo-woo.
It's not magic.
It's just the flow.
Forgive me for that.
But sometimes that happens,
and it happened to me in
writing this book.
Now I'll tell you that my
husband and I don't celebrate
the anniversary of
the day we met.
We do not.
We celebrate the anniversary
of the day before we met.
And we call that "You Never Know
Day." Because you never
know what wonderful thing is
around the next corner.
You know, one day, we didn't
know the other person existed.
The next day we met, and we
haven't been apart since then,
17 years ago.
So You Never Know Day.
You never know what's
around the corner.
And that's where this
book came from.
Remember, I said my philosophy
about good stuff
coming out of bad?
I needed a root canal.
And you wonder, what good could
come out of getting a
root canal?
So I'm in the dentist's
office.
My face is puffy, I'm cranky,
I'm missing work.
I'm going, like, oh my gosh,
I can't be here, I can't be
here, I have to go.
And I was reading an old "People
Magazine." Not--
not an old people magazine.
And old "People Magazine." And I
was reading an article about
Mark Sanford, the ex-governor
of South Carolina.
You know who that is, of course,
the one who told his
wife and his family that he was
out hiking the Appalachian
Trail when really he was off
with his Argentinean mistress.
And in the dentist's office,
in pain, puffy face, I'm
thinking who would be
the other woman?
Who would be this Argentinian
mistress?
Who would do that?
Who would actively decide
to ruin her life?
Who would actively decide to
ruin the life of this man she
ostensibly loves?
You know, we think about these
people that we've known--
I mean, first of all, you're
going to get caught.
You're going to get caught.
From Kay Summersby,
to Elizabeth
Ray, to Rielle Hunter--
I mean, Monica Lewinsky could
win the Nobel Prize, right?
And what would the
headlines say?
"Monica Lewinsky, paramour of
President Clinton, wins Nobel
Prize." Right?
It's never going to go away.
So I was just obsessed with
who would be other woman?
You're going to ruin
your life.
You're going to ruin-- the
guy you ostensibly
love, his life is ruined.
His wife's life, his family's
life, his children's life, his
employees' life, his
staff's life.
And here's a guy who is the
elected governor of a state.
And you know, all of us are
jaded and cynical and
suspicious enough of people in
politics and public service,
when really being a public
servant and giving your life
to politics and lawmaking
is the highest
calling you can have.
It's one of the most honorable
things you can do.
So I started getting cranky and
angry about why someone
would take that and--
why would someone be such a
bad guy and make everybody
else look bad, too?
So I began to wonder whether
there was a big, juicy story
that I could write
about motivation.
I began to wonder whether there
was a thriller about why
someone would be the
other woman.
Was it lust?
Was it power?
Was it corruption?
Was it need?
Was it desire?
Was it selfishness?
Or maybe there was a motivation
that I hadn't
thought of yet that would really
talk about why someone
would do that.
And in the end of this article
in "People Magazine"--
I mean, through my pain I'm
thinking about this.
In the end of this article,
someone says, you can choose
your sin, but you cannot choose
your consequences.
And I just thought, oh, my
book, my book, my book.
Because we all have, everything
we do has a
consequence.
Even when we think we're making
the right decision, it
has a consequence.
And that's what I wanted my book
to be able to be about.
It takes place in Boston.
It's very local.
You'll recognize the Esplanade
and MassPike.
I mean, my husband and I will
be driving on the MassPike,
and I"ll say, oh, exit 17, this
is where Jane gets chased
by the truck.
And I think, no,
I made that up.
So it's so realistic and so
Bostonian that sometimes I
forget what's real and
what's not real.
But it takes place right
now, actually.
In the pivotal weeks before a
Senate election, a Boston
television reporter on the
trail of an ex-governor's
secret mistress, a Boston police
detective on the trail
of a possible serial killer--
two women's bodies have been
found under bridges, the Zakim
Bridge and the BU Bridge,
specifically.
Both killed the same
way, both with no
identification and no shoes.
When the next victim is a key
player in the political
campaign the reporter
is covering--
Jane, the reporter,
when the next victim is a key
player in the political
campaign, Jane, the reporter,
and Jake, the cop, believe
that they might be on the trail
of the same person.
And this is someone who
will stop at nothing
to prevent a scandal.
So in the book, it
says, seduction,
betrayal, and murder.
It's going to take
a lot more than
votes to win this election.
So Booklist Starred Review
called it a perfect thriller
for the election season.
And you can't really do
better than perfect.
Let me just wrap up by saying
that a couple of months ago,
my husband and I went to hear
Judy Collins at Stanford
Theatre at Harvard.
Did you go?
She was so amazing.
And Judy Collins, this brilliant
icon, gorgeous
singer, told the story of how
she had been brought up as a
kid to be a concert pianist.
Her parents wanted her to be a
concert pianist, and she was
trained for that.
But she knew, she said she
always knew that she wanted to
be a folk singer.
And at age 16, she left home,
she left Denver, and ran off
to New York to become a folk
singer, to make her mark.
And she said, I went to New
York and I took all
my songs with me.
And then she said, of
course, I hadn't
written any of them yet.
And that touched me so much,
because it made me realize
that we all have songs.
And some of them we haven't
quite written yet, because we
haven't quite decided that
it's the time to do so.
She decided it was the
time to do so.
I'm the poster child for
having a time to do so.
I didn't start writing
my mysteries until I
was 55 years old.
I was 62 yesterday.
No, I was 63 yesterday.
And you know, who'd have thought
that all that work in
politics and all those
years as a reporter--
and I'm still a reporter--
weren't the end in themselves?
It wasn't about being
a reporter.
It wasn't about being a
political campaign staffer.
It was 40 years of research.
It was 40 years of research
for this part of my life,
which is so exciting.
And I tell people, you
know, if there's
something you want to do--
like make a lot of noise.
If there's something you want to
do, like write that book of
poetry or take that trip or
learning Italian or start a
business or try something
new, please do that.
You don't want to wake up one
morning and think, I regret
that I didn't try that.
I regret that I didn't
do that.
I have a motto on my bulletin
board, and it says leap, and
the net will appear.
Leap, and the net will appear.
And that's how I feel
about the world.
If not now, when are we
going to do this?
When I finished my first book,
"Prime Time," I called my
husband into the room, and I
said, sweetheart, watch this.
And I've typed, The End.
And then I burst into tears.
I burst into tears.
Because I knew no matter what
happened with that book, I had
done something that I
always wanted to do.
I had followed my dreams.
And of course, I shouldn't have
cried when I typed The
End, because it wasn't
the end.
It wasn't the end at all.
It was the beginning of
this wonderful new
second half of my life.
And I'm so happy to be here
today to share it with you.
Thank you very much
for inviting me.
[APPLAUSE]
I would be delighted to answer
any questions about reporting
or writing or mysteries, or the
mysteries of television,
or juggling two different
careers, anything like that.
Anybody have a question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So currently, you
don't write your own graphics,
but do you write your
own material as an
investigative reporter?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Do I write
my own material as an
investigative reporter?
Yes I do.
Every word.
One of the joys of being able to
tell a story is that I have
a tremendous amount
of material.
Well, I start out
with nothing.
I start out with an idea.
And then we write, we research
and do interviews, and look up
documents, and track down clues,
and follow leads, and
come up with volumes and volumes
and volumes of stuff.
And then we shoot
our interviews
and shoot our video.
We usually shoot about 18 times
more video than ever
goes on the air.
So you can imagine what it's
like to take all this
voluminous information that's
complicated and mysterious and
make it into a compelling little
movie, to narrow it to
the essence--
AUDIENCE: So you're actually
a documentary filmmaker, in
addition to all these
other things.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Well, yes,
kind of a documentary
filmmaker, because every news
story is a little movie.
Every news story that we write
is a little movie.
So we get told we have
three minutes for a
story, let's say.
So you have to figure
out how to tell the
story in three minutes.
And then sometimes if some big
breaking news thing happens,
the boss will come in and say,
well, you can only have a
minute and a half.
And so then we have to fix the
little movie to make it be the
same good story in a
minute and a half.
So your mind is always working
about how to take the very
best things that you have and
put them together so that no
one will turn the channel.
And writing those stories,
taking all the puzzle pieces
and seeing what picture it
makes, you know what I mean?
Because at the beginning,
you don't know.
Taking those puzzles pieces
and seeing what picture it
makes in the most compelling
ways is really one of the most
fun parts of my job.
Who else has a question?
Yes, Kathleen?
AUDIENCE: I have to assume that
a certain amount of your
experience is going in
there, in being Jane.
And I'm wondering how you can
take someone who is supposed
to have the naivete of maybe
being willing to sniff a
little lighter fluid, but also
has the good sense to know
when the license is
being renewed for
the local radio station--
with all of your experience, how
do you keep her from being
too smart to be believable?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Oh,
that's so interesting.
How do I keep my main character
from being too smart
to be believable?
That's funny.
I've never been asked that, and
that's a terrific question.
What I try to do with my
characters is make them be
real, someone who you
might really know.
And one of the magical--
it's not magic.
But one of the amazing things
about writing is how you're
making a real character
out of something that
didn't exist before.
You know the Stephen Sondheim
musical, "Sunday in the Park
with George?" Have you
seen that at all?
It's about creativity
and it's about--
he's painting--
he has a blank canvas, and
he sings this song called
"Finishing the Hat." And
he's painting this hat.
And he says, look, I
made a hat where
there never was a hat.
And that's how I feel about
creating my characters.
I'm creating something
out of nothing.
I'm making a person who never
was there before.
I'm making hats, new hats,
everyday as a writer.
So Jane, or all of
my characters--
I don't have an outline.
I don't know where the
books are going.
Everything that happens
is a surprise.
So I see how she would
really behave.
Sometimes my characters say
things that I hadn't planned
for them to say.
Sometimes they won't say the
things that I had planned for
them to say.
What I worry more about--
I worry more about not making
a character do something
that's silly.
I don't want people to say,
you would never do that.
You see the movies or read the
books, or you think, don't go
in the basement.
You know, the bad guy
is in the basement.
At least in the movies,
they have the music.
When that music starts,
you don't go in there.
What I worry more about than
making her too smart--
because she's vulnerable, and
she's 33, and Jane is learning
her way in the news business.
She's been unfairly fired.
She's been humiliated.
She's trying to get her
reputation back in this book.
So I dig for my own personal
experiences in those emotions
of being 33, which now at 63,
I can look back on that in a
certain way and take the things
that work and not take
the things that don't work.
So I never thought about not
making her too smart.
I have thought about making
her too dumb.
Isn't that so interesting?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You said this was your
first hardcover, which I
always assumed that books
started as hardcover and then
went to paperback.
So the earlier books started
as paperbacks?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Yes.
You're asking about my first
hardcover, and that you
thought that all books
started as hardcover.
No.
Some books start as what they
call paperback originals.
And they can be the mass market
size, which is the
pocketbook size, and then
there's the trade paperbacks
which are bigger and more sort
of elegant-looking and more
expensive, and then the
hardcover books.
And the publisher decides how
they're going to use your
manuscript, and how they're
going to make that look,
whether it's going
to be a hardcover
like this or a paperback.
Paperback originals
are fabulous.
You can tuck them in your
pocket, you can
tuck them your briefcase.
You read them fast, and they're
not a treasure, but
they are convenient.
I mean, look at this--
it's beautiful.
It's embossed, it's metallic.
When my agent got the book, she
called me and she said,
wait 'til you see your book.
It's so delicious.
I could eat it.
But she's enthusiastic.
So the publisher decides
what's going to be a
hardcover, what's going
to be a paperback.
They decide the print run,
they decide what the
distribution, they decide
what the cover's
going to look like.
They decide everything.
The author is just
happy that their
book is going to published.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested in the
editing process. 'Cause I
know you said you got to the
end of your first book and
wrote The End, but I would guess
that's the beginning of
going through the whole
editing process.
I was just wondering what that
was like, maybe your first
time around, and then what was
different this time around,
because you had done
it before.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: The editing
process is really one
of my favorite parts.
It is so interesting to see
the book that you meant to
write emerge from all the
junk that you take out.
You asked about my first book.
When I wrote "Prime
Time," I took--
do we have time?
What's our timing?
We're OK.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: OK.
When I wrote my first book, I
took the disk that the book
was on to the Kinko's--
this is how long ago it was.
I went to the Kinko's and
I said, could you
print this for me?
It's my novel.
And the guy says, yeah, OK.
And so just like in-- did you
see the movie "Sideways?" And
so just like in "Sideways,"
I come back to get my book
later, and I said, I'm here
to pick up my printing.
And the guy says, oh, you're
the one with the novel.
And I thought, oh, he read it.
He read it and he loves it.
So I said, yes.
So he says, OK, here.
And he bends down and he picks
up a ream box and puts it on
the counter.
I said, OK, thank you.
And he goes, no, wait.
And he bends down and picks
up another ream box.
It was 723 pages long.
You know, a book can be
like 322 pages long.
I was such a newbie that I
hadn't numbered the pages,
first of all.
So in answer to your
question--
finally--
I had to cut 400 pages
from my book.
I had to cut 400 pages.
And that was the most
educational, fabulous,
wonderful experience that I've
ever had in writing, because
it made me question every single
word, every single
scene, every single idea
that I had in the book.
So I went through and I asked
myself, why is this here?
Why do they say this?
What it this scene for?
What is this paragraph for?
Why did I choose this
particular word?
There are 10 words here.
Can I make it into one word?
What's the concept of
this entire page?
Can I take this one page and
make it into one word?
Do I really need it?
Do I need it at all?
And that editing process, I
mean, I just got goosebumps
thinking about it.
When you're writing and your
brain just sort of flows
sometimes, you're just going
to put stuff down that's
vamping and transition.
When you go back and look at it,
when you go back and look
at the editing, you see what's
derivative, you see what's
stupid, you see the parts where
you thought, oh, I'm
such a good writer-- and that's
the part that's got to
go, because you know, that's
just showing off.
You see what's repetitive.
You see what's unintentional,
see what's tangential.
I cut everything that wasn't the
story, is what happened.
I cut everything that
wasn't the story.
And when I saw what was left,
that was fabulous.
So the difficult part for me is
writing that first draft,
and I just power through
and write the story.
And then I go back
and look at it.
Using the skills that I learned
in my first book, I
try not to write that
stuff now anyway.
So my stories don't turn out
to be 700 pages long.
But they're always, you know,
10,000 words too long.
And I generally have to
cut 10,000 words.
And it's wonderful.
It's like making a statue, and
you cut away the parts you
don't need, and then
that's what left.
I have a wonderful editor now,
who as I'm writing, I'm
writing for myself, and then
I'm writing as her.
You know, I think, what would
Kristin say about this?
So I use what she's taught
me too, to make a
difference in the book.
But I know that shorter
is always better.
Cute never works.
And just tell the story.
Is that what you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I also wonder, sometimes, if
there was things like you find
the deleted scenes at the end
of movies sometimes, the
scenes that they pulled out
because they just didn't work.
But sometimes those are the
director's favorite.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so I wonder, did
you go through that process,
where some of you favorite
parts of the
book, you had to cut?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: I
love deleted scenes.
I love deleted scenes.
I watch them all the time,
because I do think, just as
you say, that they give a
fresh look at what the
director was trying to convey.
But you know, when you're in a
movie and you're kind of going
like this and trying to
see what time it is?
That's what I do in
my books, too.
I think, I love this, but
people are going to be
thinking, you know, maybe
I should make dinner.
I don't want your attention
to stray.
But I'll tell you, unlike
fabulous directors whose
deleted scenes are so fabulous
that they leave them on the
DVDs, when I cut a scene, part
of the power of cutting is I
think, I have this.
I've written this.
I can keep this, and I can
use this another time.
So I'm not making
it disappear.
I'm just moving it
to another place.
And when I go back and
look at them later,
they're just awful.
It's awful.
They're terrible.
It's nothing you
would ever use.
I think, how could I ever
have written this?
How could I ever have thought
this was good?
So my deleted scenes
are better deleted.
But I love to find them.
There's the power in finding
what's wrong.
You know what I mean?
There's the power of finding
your mistake and recognizing
that, and having the nerve
to take it out.
And then at the end,
you think, yay.
It's better now,
and I did that.
That's education.
That's learning.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You seem
very positive
about your entire career.
And I always thought that an
important part of being an
investigative reporter would
involve making a lot of people
very angry at you.
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Wanting to sue you,
or even just throw you off a
bridge somewhere.
AUDIENCE: Yes, indeed.
People have--
throw me off a bridge.
That's a good idea for a book.
Yes.
I've had a lot of people be very
upset with me and very
angry with me.
I've gotten a lot of threats--
threats of violence, threats
of lawsuits.
I've never been held at
gunpoint, like Jane is.
But I have had people
come to my house.
I have had people send
me nasty letters.
I've had many threats
of violence,
many threats of lawsuits.
People say to me, people who
are in my stories say, how
could you do that to me?
How could you do that?
You wrecked my life.
And I say, I didn't
do anything.
You did.
I just told.
And that's a different deal.
And I am so careful--
knock on wood--
Formica.
And I'm so careful
to be right, if
you know what I mean?
The stress of being an
investigative reporter not
only has to do with coming up
with a good story, but in my
job I can never be wrong.
I can never be wrong.
I can never make a mistake.
I could never be
a minute late.
I can never choose
the wrong word.
You know what I mean?
So that's a lot of pressure.
And so when my stories are on
the air, they're right.
I feel like I need to
touch Formica again.
They're right.
And so I don't feel
bad about making
someone's life miserable.
When was the last time you
heard a quote like that?
[LAUGHTER]
Because I didn't do it.
They did it.
And also, the thing about
being an investigative
reporter for television is
that when you're out on a
story, I have a photographer
with me, right?
So I say to him, if it looks
like somebody's going to haul
off and hit me, make sure
you're rolling.
[LAUGHTER]
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: You know?
'Cause who's going to hurt a
reporter when it's going
to be on tape?
So I'm laughing now, but I
take it very seriously.
And when I'm in my
reporter role, I
take it very seriously.
I do a lot of research.
I do a lot of homework.
I'd do a lot of soul-searching,
actually.
I use the Chip Landman rule.
My brother's name
is Chip Landman.
And I say to myself, if someone
were doing a story
about my brother, would
I think that what
I'm doing is fair?
Do you know what I mean?
I try to put myself in the shoes
of a person who's being
targeted in a story, and I see
whether I would think, if
somebody did it to my brother,
would it be fair?
And if yes, then I just do it.
That's my job as a reporter, to
reveal when something bad
has happened.
But I try--
in television, I know you've
heard this, but it's called
compassion fatigue.
And it's very prevalent among
reporters who've been
around a long time.
You just start thinking,
oh, I don't care.
I don't care.
Just go away.
So I work very hard
not to have that.
I work very hard to respect each
person who comes to me,
to respect each story that comes
to me, to listen to each
person who comes to me, and
to make the best and most
honorable decision that I can,
knowing that I have this huge
responsibility.
And a little bit of power to
change the world a little bit,
if things go right.
Does that answer
your question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It seems like you
live in two worlds.
You live in the fiction
world and you live in
this reality world.
And you know, in the fiction
world, you can create
characters.
Is there sometimes the
temptation, as you're putting
together a story, to, you know,
maybe present things a
little differently to make
your story better?
Or how do you balance that?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: You're
asking whether there's a
temptation to tweak the
story a little bit to
make the story better.
No.
I mean, no.
I mean, one of the
things that's
wonderful about reality--
you can just write all
this stuff down.
One of the things that's
wonderful about reality is
that it's always fascinating,
it's always interesting, and
the realness of it is
what's compelling.
And the realness of what people
say is better than
anything I could ever make up.
So no, I have no problem keeping
my absolute reality in
journalism separate from my
whatever-I-want-to-do
imagination in writing
fiction.
I wondered, actually, initially,
whether my brain
would do it, whether my brain
could make stuff up.
You know what I mean?
Because for the last however
many years, I've never made
anything up.
I never--
I create how something looks.
I write a story, and I'm in
the booth with the video
editor, making a little movie
with graphics and effects and
sound and music, and it's
a little movie.
So I'm creative, but what's
true is true, and
what's real is real.
And I wondered if my brain would
let me make stuff up.
I was happy to realize
that it did.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You sound kind of
like a prosecutor to me.
Your husband is a defense
attorney.
How does that work?
HANK PHILLIPPI RYAN: She's
saying, I sound like a
prosecutor, and my husband
is a defense attorney.
How does that work?
I never thought of myself
as a prosecutor.
I see why.
I look at myself as defending
the little guy, rather than
prosecuting, rather than going
after the bad guy.
I look at myself as the
person who stands up
for the little guy.
I'm trying to make
the system work.
I'm trying to make it be fair.
When I was growing up, I
would say to my mom,
but that isn't fair.
And she's say, the
world isn't fair.
And I would say, why not?
Why not?
And that's one of the reasons
I decided to be a reporter,
too, is that I wanted to make
the world be a fairer place.
So I look at myself as
a defense person too.
I do go after the bad guys.
Certainly I do.
But I do that for making the
world be a better place.
My husband is a really wonderful
civil rights and
criminal defense attorney.
He represented Muhammad Ali in
the Supreme Court in his
conscientious objector case,
and has done a lot of
wonderful work.
So it's wonderful to have
in-house counsel.
That's what's good about having
a lawyer husband.
I can say, I need to keep this
guy in jail for another day.
How would I do that?
How do I get a search warrant?
I need to keep someone
in custody.
What would a lawyer say?
What would a lawyer do?
Or what would the police say?
So having in-house counsel
is fabulous.
My husband is also incredibly
supportive.
Incredibly hilarious.
He read my first book,
page by page--
I'll tell this fast.
Read my first book,
page by page.
He read the first five pages.
I heard him laughing.
I was so happy.
I hid around the corner
to get the response.
I'm so needy.
So he reads the first five
pages, laughing.
The next day, he reads the next
five pages, laughing.
At about page 50, I'm hiding
around the corner, waiting for
my daily dose of approval.
And I hear nothing.
I hear nothing.
So I came out, and I
said, oh it's bad.
It's bad, isn't it?
I can't write.
I should never have done this.
This is a bad idea.
It's terrible, isn't it?
And he says, sweetheart,
is something
going to happen soon?
So that was my first--
that was my first bit
of knowledge--
in a book, something
has to happen.
So that's what I learned after
all those years, that writing
a page-turning novel is
what I want to do.
I'm so thrilled that
the second part of
my career is fiction.
Thank you all very much
for being here today.
[APPLAUSE]